kollegin voraussichtlich letzter redner
in dieser debatte aber halt weiß man nie
ist der kollege alexander throm cdu/csu
und ich bitte ihn genauso genauso viel
möglichkeit zu geben zuzuhören wie alle
anderen redner sehr guter präsident
werde kolleginnen und kollegen wir
machen heute mit der koalition einen
großen schritt zur besseren steuerung
der migration nach deutschland für
gewünscht gewünschte migration von
fachkräften aber auch wieder zur
beendigung illegalen aufenthalts hier in
deutschland ja abschiebungen sind die
unschöne ist der unschöne teil unseres
flüchtlings systems aber er gehört dazu
und wird die akzeptanz in der
bevölkerung für den umfassenden
flüchtlingsschutz aufrechterhalten will
der muss auch dafür sorgen dass
asylbewerber die rechtskräftig abgelehnt
sind dann auch das land tatsächlich und
nicht nur in der theorie wieder
verlassen
und das gehört auch zum
verantwortungsbewusstsein der
entscheidung hier im bundestag und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von linke und
grüne
sie machen sie werfen der afd oft eine
plumpe stimmungsmache vor
zu recht das haben wir heute wieder
hören müssen
aber sie machen dasselbe heute hier mit
ihren wort äußerungen nur mit anderen
vorzeichen
sie zeichnen hier ein zerrbild unseres
verhaltens mit flüchtlingen hier in
deutschland das mit der realität
wirklich nichts zu tun hat liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben offenkundig ein
vollzugsdefizit hier in deutschland über
50 prozent aller abschnitt und versuche
im letzten jahr sind im versuchsstadium
stecken geblieben deshalb stellen wir
heute als koalitionsfraktionen auch
anträge die das gute gesetz der
regierung doch etwas verbessern wird
erstmals soll es ein bundesweites
betreten
und durchsuchungs recht geben er konnte
geheim
gestatten sie eine zwischenfrage der
kollegin bernburg gerne tut mir leid
so ist das in ordnung das parlament
heißt diskussion jetzt zu einer
zwischenfrage kollegen bei vielen dank
herr präsident vielen dank herr throm
dass sie wir es zulassen damit man sich
austauschen kann
da war ja viel über das verfahren
gesprochen haben und weniger über den
inhalt des gesetzes und hier ja auch
immer dinge in den raum gestellt werden
dass gesetze nicht angewandt würden das
ja auch in grüner regierungsbeteiligung
in ländern dinge nicht angewandt würden
würde ich gerne zum inhalt des gesetzes
eine frage an sie stellen es geht hier
um die frage von menschen die wie sie
sagen die müssen abgeschoben werden und
es finden viele abschiebungen nicht
statt weil wir eine rechtsordnung haben
die besagt die menschen müssen
vollziehbar ausreisepflichtig sein
es geht hierbei der debatte nicht darum
um diejenigen die einfach so abgeschoben
werden können da gibt es
unterschiedliche probleme in
unterschiedlichen bundesländern warum
das nicht zu tage kommt sie machen jetzt
ein gesetz für all diejenigen das wurde
im vorherigen wortbeitrag ja noch mal
deutlich all diejenigen menschen die
nicht ausreisen und natürlich davon ob
sie überhaupt vollziehbar
ausreisepflichtig sind auf die findet
dieses gesetz anwendung und da möchte
ich sie jetzt fragen insbesondere mit
den blickpunkt das in diesem gesetz ja
auch mit drin steht dass die menschen
nicht mehr arbeiten können die in der
bildungs sind und die irgendwann mal
ihre papiere nicht beschaffen können zum
beispiel in mecklenburg vorpommern in
der gastronomie arbeiten als afghanen
konterkarieren damit ihr einwanderungs
fachkräfte gesetzt und ich frage sie
wollen sie wirklich dass in zukunft
menschen die ich jetzt zehn jahre gelebt
haben die hier berufstätig sind die
kinder haben durch dieses geordnete
rückkehr gesetzt nicht mehr arbeiten
können und damit die teilhabe dieser
menschen und vor allem in ihrer kinder
am gesellschaftlichen leben nicht mehr
möglich ist
sehr geehrte frau kollegin werbung für
sie war die beratungszeit offensichtlich
wirklich zu kurz weil sie haben das
gesetz gelesen denn dann müssten sie
dann wissen sie dass es nicht nur um die
menschen geht die eine so genannte
bildung haben und für die die duldung
mit umgekehrter intimität greifen soll
sondern auch die menschen die vom
ausreisepflichtig sind deren wer aber am
abschiebe tag nicht hab aber werden und
bei den menschen mit ungeklärter
identität ist die ausreisepflicht
gegeben
es sind etwa 184 tausend menschen
momentan in deutschland davon etwa 40
prozent bei denen keine pass papiere
vorliegt und dann ist es doch nur
logisch und richtig wenn wir alles von
ihnen zumutbare fordert damit sie sich
bei der pass papier beschaffung
beteiligen
und wer das nicht tut der hat in der tag
der hat in der tat mit konsequenzen zu
rechnen
etwa dass er keine arbeitserlaubnis mehr
erhält weil diese menschen gruppe muss
ist sie bitte zu ich habe ihnen auch zu
gehören
diese menschengruppe muss dann erkennen
dass ihre perspektive ihr in deutschland
nicht gegeben ist
und wenn ich gerade so wenn ich gerade
so bei ihnen bin ich habe gerade neben
davon gesprochen dass die linken und die
grünen auch eine plumpe stimmungsmache
machen und jetzt habe ich mir auch nach
ihrem auftritt gestern abend im
fernsehen heute mal zugeschaut was die
grünen auf ihrer homepage
veröffentlichen
da steht die möglichkeiten menschen in
ausreise gewahrsam zu nehmen werden noch
weiter ausgeweitet
soweit wichtig und gut einer
richterlichen anordnung bedarf es nicht
mehr
somit grob falsch grobe unkenntnis mein
alter jura bruch hat immer gesagt ein
blick ins gesetz erleichtert die
rechtsfindung das hätte sie denn liebe
kolleginnen erkennen auch einmal genutzt
und ist übrigens wir haben beim ausreise
gewahrsam
eine richterliche anordnung aber als
einziges land in europa ließ dies noch
mit richtervorbehalt stellt und nicht
von den verwaltungen entscheiden lässt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und ein
weiterer punkt ich habe es gesagt der
großteil der menschen werden wir am
abschiebe tag nicht habe und wir haben
die anhörung diesem montag durchgeführt
ich hoffe sie haben bei dieser anhörung
auch gut zugehört insbesondere dem
leiter der berliner ausländerbehörde
hermann zanker
der hat nämlich gesagt dass wir ganz
dringend ein betretens und durchsuchungs
recht brauchen ich zitiere wir brauchen
ganz ganz dringend eine
bundesgesetzliche klare regelung und er
hat es insbesondere damit begründet dass
es hier um die eigensicherung der
polizeibeamten geht dass es um ihren
eigenen schutz an leib und leben geht
wenn sie mit widerstand bei einer
abschiebe maßnahme rechnen müssen und
deswegen kommen wir dieser aufforderung
der praxis mit unserem änderungsantrag
heute auch nach und ich nicht den
innenminister sehen in den ländern der
dann diese regelung zum ausreise
gewahrsam und zum betretungsrecht nicht
anwenden lässt und seiner bevölkerung
erklären muss dass er die abschiebung
nicht effektiv durchführt und vor allem
seine polizeibeamten nicht ordentlich
geschützt insofern haben wir glauben ich
heute ein gutes maßnahmenpaket um der
rechts geld und wirklich zur
durchsetzung zu verhelfen und ich will
dass sie auch im abschluss auch noch
einmal tun möchte mich ausdrücklich bei
den ministerien und vor allem auch bei
den kolleginnen und kollegen der spd
fraktion für die gute und konstruktive
zusammenarbeit und den beratungen
bedanken hat sich im dank ich bitte um
zustimmung
[Applaus]